CARTER MORGAN:
Today, we're talking
about Workspace webinars, subsea
cables, the how and whys of
AI, and Ubuntu Pro.
I'm Carter Morgan, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Whether your team is
heading back to the office
or exploring a variety
of hybrid models,
Google Workspace will help you
adapt and make the most of it.
Over the past year, we've
announced a variety of updates
to Google Workspace
from companion mode
to hybrid collaboration tools.
Sign up for our free
upcoming webinar on July 28
to learn more.
Firmina, an open
subsea cable, will
run from the East
Coast of the US
to Argentina, with additional
landings in Brazil and Uruguay.
Firmina will be
the longest cable
in the world capable of running
entirely from a single power
source at one end of the
cable if its other power
sources become temporarily
unavailable, a resilience boost
at a time when reliable
connectivity is
more important than ever.
Many companies today
are actively using AI
or have plans to incorporate it
into their future strategies.
But as AI and advanced
analytics become more pervasive,
the need for more transparency
around how AI technology works
will be paramount.
Decision-makers want
to know the reasons
behind an AI-based decision
so they have the confidence
that it's the right one.
Check out the blog to learn
more about why and how you
need to explain ML models.
We're pleased to announce the
general availability of Ubuntu
Pro images on Google
Cloud, providing customers
with an improved Ubuntu
experience, expanded security
coverage, and integration with
critical Google Cloud features.
In partnership with Canonical,
we're making it even easier
for customers that have fully
embraced open source to ensure
security and compliance
for their most
mission-critical
enterprise workloads.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or Tweet us,
and we'll see you in the Cloud.